you might recognize what we have here in
yellow as the general form of a p-series
and what we're going to do in this video
is think about under which conditions
under for what Peas
will this pea series converge and for it
to be a p-series by definition P is
going to be greater than zero so I've
set up some visualizations to think
about how we are going to understand
when this pea series converges so over
here you have the graph this curve right
here that's y is equal to 1 over X to
the P and we're saying it in general
terms because P is greater than 0 we
know it's going to be a decreasing
function like this once again that's y
is equal to 1 over X to the P and now
what we've shaded in ahead of time
underneath that curve above the positive
x-axis that is the integral from 1 to
infinity from 1 to infinity improper
integral of 1 over X to the P DX so
that's this area that I have already
shaded in you see it in white in both of
these graphs and we're going to
hopefully see visually is that there's a
very close convergence or divergence
relationship between this P Series and
this integral right over here because
when we when we when we look at this
left-hand graph we see that this P
series can be viewed as an upper riemann
approximation of that area what is that
what do I mean by that well think about
think about the area of this first I
guess you could say this first rectangle
the width is 1 and its height is 1 over
1 over 1 to the P so this would be the
first term in this piece here is it this
would this would just be an area of 1
this the scale the x and y scales are
not the same this one right over here
it's area would be 1 over 2 to the P
this area is 1 over 3 to P so the sum of
the areas of these rectangles that is
what this P Series is and you can see
that each of these rectangles they are
covering more than the area under the
curve and so we know the area under the
curve that's going to be greater than 0
this P series is going to be greater
than
this integral greater than the area
under the curve but if we add one to the
area under the curve so now we're not
just talking about the wide area we're
also talking about this red area here
well then our piece Erie is going to be
less than that because the first term of
our P series is equal to one and then
all of the other terms you can view it
as a lower riemann approximation of the
curve and you can see they fit under the
curve and they leave some area so this
is going to be less than that expression
there now think about what happens if we
know if we know that this right over
here diverges so if this improper
integral diverges it doesn't converge to
a finite value well this the P series is
greater than that so if this diverges
then that's going to diverge similarly
if this converges the same integral
right over here if this converges it
goes to a finite value well 1 plus that
is still going to converge and so this
the our P series must also converge it
must go to a finite value and what I'm
all on one all I'm talking about right
here this is really just the integral
test when we when we think about tests
of convergence and divergence but I'm
just making sure that we have a nice
conceptual understanding and not just
blindly applying the integral test so
and you could go the other way too if
the P series converges then for sure
this integral is going to converge and
if the P series diverges and for sure
this expression right over here is going
to diverge on D and the integral
diverges so we can say the P series
converges if and only if this integral
right over here converges so figuring
out under what conditions for what P
does the P series converge where it's
boiling down to under what conditions
does this integral converge so let's
scroll on down to give us some real
estate to think about what has to be
true for that integral to converge so
I'm going to rewrite it so we've got the
integral from 1 to infinity improper
integral of 1 over X to the P DX this is
the same thing this is the limit as I'll
use the variable M since we're already
using n as m approaches infinity and the
integral from 1
to M of one over and actually let me
just write that as X to the negative P X
to the negative P DX and let me just
focus on this and we'll just remember
that we're gonna have to take the limit
as M approaches infinity I don't have to
keep writing that over and over again so
let's think about what this is so
there's a couple of conditions we know
we already know that P is greater than
zero we know that P is greater than zero
but there's two situations right over
here there's one situation when P is
equal to 1 if P is equal to 1 then this
is just the integral of 1 over X and so
this thing is going to be the integral
of Ln of X and we're going to go from 1
to M and so this would be the natural
log of M minus the natural log of 1 well
e to the 0 power is 1 so the natural log
I'll write it out the natural log of 1
but the natural log of 1 is just 0 so
when in the in a special case I guess
you can say when P equals 1 this
integral from 1 to M comes down to the
natural log of M now let's think about
the situation where P does not equal the
where P does not equal 1 well there were
kind of just reversing the power rule
that we learned in basic differentiation
so we increment that exponent so it
would be X to the negative P plus 1 and
we could even write that as X to the 1
minus P that's the same thing as
negative P plus 1 and then we would
divide by that so 1 minus P and we would
go we are going to good we are going to
go from 1 to M and so this is going to
be equal to we could write this as m to
the 1 minus P over 1 minus P minus 1 to
the 1 minus P over 1 minus P so now
let's take the limits so we remember
this integral we won't take the
antiderivative or the definite integral
here but then we want to the limit as n
approaches infinity so what is the limit
as M approaches infinity of natural log
of natural log of M well if M go
unbounded to infinity well the natural
log of that is still going to go to is
still going to go to infinity so when P
equals 1 this thing doesn't converge
this thing is just unbounded so P equals
1 we diverge so we know that so now
let's look over here let's think about
the limit as M approaches infinity of
this expression right over here and the
only part that's really affected by the
limit is the part that has M so we could
even write this as we could take this 1
over 1 minus P out of this we could say
1 over 1 minus P times the limit as n
approaches infinity of m to the 1 minus
P and then separately we can subtract 1
to the 1 minus PE well for any exponent
that's just going to be 1 over 1 minus P
is that right yeah no matter what
exponent I put up here 1 to any power is
what's going to be 1 and so the
interesting thing about whether it
converges or not is this part of the
expression right over here it's all
going to depend on whether this exponent
is positive or negative if 1 minus P is
greater than 0 well if I'm taking a a if
I'm going to infinity and I'm taking
that thing to a positive exponent well
then this is going to diverge and so in
this situation we diverge and 1 minus P
is greater than 0 we can add P to both
sides that's the situation that's the
same thing as 1 being greater than P or
P being less than 1 we are going to
diverge so far we know that P is going
to be greater than 0 and so we saw if P
is 1 or if it's less than 1 we're going
to diverge but if this exponent right
over here is negative if 1 minus P is
less than 0 well think about it then
it's going to be then it's going to be 1
over m to some positive exponent is one
way to think about it
so as m approaches infinity this whole
thing is going to approach 0 so this is
actually going to be a situation where
we converge where we get to a finite
value and so we add P to both sides we
have 1 is less than P we converge so
there you have it we have established
this integral is going to converge only
in the situation where P is greater than
one P greater than one you are going to
converge and if zero is less than P is
less than or equal to one you are going
to diverge and those are then the exact
because this the R P series converges if
and only if this integral converges and
so these exact same constraints apply to
our original P series our original P
series converges only in the situation
where P is greater than 1 then we
converge and if zero is less than P is
less than or equal to 1 we diverge there
you go